the sporting world reacts to the russian
invasion of ukraine coming up
condemnation of russian president
vladimir putin as world sport takes a
stand from the football pitch to the
paralympics and motor racing bans
implemented and events cancelled as the
door is slowly shut on russia
for the first time in recent memory we
are seeing the likes of fifa uefa and
other giants crumble under global
pressure to take a united front russian
teams are banned from competition
sporting events are moved or cancelled
altogether sponsorships across all
sports and divisions are ended these are
just some of the outcomes so far as the
international sporting community moves
to further isolate russia
for 15 years german football club
schalke played with the logo of russia's
state-owned energy company gazprom on
their shirts
now the partnership worth 9 million
euros a year to the club was abruptly
cut short and players strode out in
altered jerseys for the first time on
saturday
across the bundesliga's first and second
tiers clubs and fans denounced president
vladimir putin and his military's
invasion of ukraine pleas for peace
could be seen around the grounds and all
games were preceded by a moment of
silence
similar sentiments were expressed across
the sporting landscape around the world
formula one abandoned the russian grand
prix scheduled for september in sochi
while allowing russian drivers to
compete under a neutral flag this season
meanwhile russian president vladimir
putin himself a black belt judoka has
been stripped of his title as honorary
president of the international judo
federation the most senior official
position he held in the world of sports
and european football's governing body
uefa stripped saint petersburg's gazprom
arena of the hosting rights for this
year's champions league final
like schalke uefa has also decided to
cut ties with gazprom the energy giant
was one of the organization's key
sponsors since 2012. the partnership
worth 40 million euros a year had
previously already attracted criticism
russia is being told clearly that at
present it is unwelcome in the world of
sports
one of the first athletes to openly
condemn vladimir putin's aggression in
ukraine was vladislav
just weeks ago you may have seen his
face and his call for peace during the
winter olympics in beijing he's the
ukrainian skeleton athlete who put his
no war message out there after one of
his runs at the games as russia was
amassing nearly 200 000 troops on his
country's borders
vladislavian joins me now from northwest
ukraine welcome to dw
uh the ioc and china both said that
athletes shouldn't protest but you did
so anyway tell us about that moment
i i would not call it protest it's
i will call it call
because i'm not mention any other
country i just mentioned my country and
that i want to peace in my country and i
want a peace for people who lives in my
country
and i mean you're back home now and
you're in and out of bomb shelters and
you could even be asked to fight have
you heard anything yet and
do explain for our viewers what the
situation is like where you are
now where you are where i am it's now
for a moment uh
only syrians play but i don't hear
explosions but i hear it that morning at
yesterday evening so
it's absolutely terrible to see what i
see and
i spoke with my friends
around the ukraine and
it's it's terrible situation they like
russian attacks
kids they attack civilians
so it's it's terrible and
it's terrible that our all families in
ukraine's suffering now
because of this invasion and
it's i hope it will end shortly
that's understandable have you um been
spoken to about joining forces to help
fight has that been a discussion you've
had yet
i wonder but
suddenly i don't have any experience in
military sync i'm not a professional
soldier i'm a
professional artist an olympian so i
fight on a my platform and i
fight on
my way this uh support the world
community
i mean that's exactly that's the most
important point you are of course an
athlete and you were one of the athletes
who was demanding that russia and
belarus be suspended from competitions i
mean despite the international
paralympics committee's decision very
little has actually changed for russian
athletes what did you think when you
heard the news
it's unacceptable it's very important to
mention the
russian outlets not only in olympic
sports but olympic sports also like
olympic paralympic they all
members of uh military russian military
so they have straight connection to
to the war what we have now
uh secondly like invention of ukraine
it's a very big bridge in olympic and
paralympic charters and uh
they have they should have strong
sanctions but now it looks like
nothing's changed for them and they
already compete under natural [ __ ]
virgin olympic games
and
also like as we know
athletes is a face of the country in
some way in some side of the
view so
i like they use athletes as propaganda i
already got a lot of messages from
russia and i show it
one of them in instagram my in so
russian outlet wish me like get bomb in
my house so they their minds are already
in propaganda
and they they should be suspended from
from the sport
thank you for that but uh
do stay safe thank you for talking to us
and since we talked to vladislav
the international paralympic committee
has indeed banned russian and belarusian
athletes from competing at the
paralympics
previously the ipc had said competitors
from the two countries would take part
as neutrals however it has changed that
decision a day before the beijing games
were due to start with athletes already
in china to take part
football's world governing body fifa has
suspended russian teams from all
competitions the decision bans russia
from the upcoming world cup playoffs the
women's euros and the men's world cup
here is a look at a frantic few days in
world football as fifa was convinced to
take a stand
russia hosted the last men's world cup
in 2018
russian president vladimir putin and
fifa boss johnny infantino acted like
best friends
even then many in football were
uncomfortable with russia hosting a
world cup following its 2014 annexation
of crimea
now after the invasion of ukraine
throwing russia out of this year's
tournament in qatar in november and
december has become the big topic for
the globe's biggest sport even if russia
had not even qualified yet
fifa condemns as well
the use of force
by russia and ukraine
violence is never
a solution
fifa initially said russia could no
longer hold any international matches at
home
with neutral venues used without any
fans no russian flags or anthems would
be permitted and the national team would
be known as football union of russia
rather than russia
but this was not enough of a punishment
for the invasion of ukraine according to
poland sweden
and the czech republic
those nations were future or potential
opponents for the russians in march's
playoffs for qatar
after consultations with our players on
the polish national team
the decision was made that it does not
matter in what location we do not want
to play against russia and this way we
want to show our protest against putin's
aggression against ukraine
england followed suit in saying they
would not play russia for the
foreseeable future this all gave fifa no
real wiggle room when it came to russia
playing at the world cup with the
international olympic committee also
adding to the pressure
despite infantino's close bond with
putin he's been left with little choice
[Music]
let's get a global interview now from
the group global athlete cara o'donovan
is a former world champion kickboxer and
now speaking to uh speaking two and four
world-class athletes around the world
thank you very much for joining us and
welcome to the show
we're seeing some unprecedented
decisions considering how reluctant
global sports has been in the past to
punish russia is it too little too late
in your eyes
yeah i think like while there's been a
huge amount of statements coming out
from different sports federations i
think first of all we have to look at
what the detail says and like the
olympics for example on monday they
really did pass the book they haven't
actually sanctioned the olympic
committees of russia and belarus and so
we need it needs to go further and it's
definitely late in the day um so we we
have to see more sanctions um starting
with the banning of athletes in russia
our farm russia and belarus in the
paralympic games will start this week
some say that although this is part of
sports washing i mean could you tell us
what that is exactly and how it works
right well sports washing is certainly
not a new concept it is used by a lot of
authoritarian regimes to cover up for
example human rights abuses and i know
beijing olympics and paralympics have
been widely criticized for the use of
sports watching um sport has been an
enormous part of russia's political
agenda both you know domestically and
internationally and
so that's why we are calling on um
severe sanctions on russia and belarus
because they will use these games they
will use sport
to cover up um
to cover up unjust actions at home and
to use this as part of their agenda and
it's something that we are seeing more
and more of because the likes of sports
the ioc in particular they've been
complicit in this they've been very very
happy to sit by and allow these types of
countries um use sport um for all the
wrong reasons
you say that they've been complicit um
do you think international sporting
bodies have actually learned from this
do you think they will act differently
when they host countries in the future
it's you know it's hard to answer that
question there's part of me that's a
little optimistic but i have heard
people say that this is a huge there's
been a huge change now when we see all
these sports federations come out with
statements like they have with severe
sanctions and you know we have to
recognize that's not true this is only
the start but i do think the fact that
there has been so much public pressure a
lot of that pressure has come from
athletes and that has forced a small
piece of change and i would be very
hopeful that athletes are going to grow
from this and
just put more and more pressure on
sports federations to make sure that
they don't get away with this
cara o'donovan from athlete leg group
global athlete thank you so much for
joining us
you